the Joe Rogan experience I just recently
went home to the Bahamas and I'm
starting to miss it more and more and
more because as I get older I'm long for
the things that I did as a little kid I
learned the places I thought I was at as
a little kid and so my family's from
this little place called farming ski
Exuma that's three-quarters of a mile by
7/8 I think I told you that before and
it's tiny and I was there this time and
just seeing just just waking up every
morning and just looking out the window
and just blue ocean only I just I want
to go back there the people at people
the people that live there like you get
a boat at like 14 15 years old because
you there's really nothing that you can
do an island other than interact with
the family and fish right everything
everything for everything that you need
staple wise you have to go somewhere
else to get or has to be brought in so
like I have a cousin who is like he's
older than me he's like my grandmother's
generation but he's my cousin he's like
four years older than me but like this
guy he free dives and he will go down
and he will hang out on the water for
like two or three minutes like with us
with a spear he doesn't he doesn't like
to scooby doesn't like to take um take a
tank with him one time we're we're
fishing off the back of boat he's off
the front and he's like he and then on
top of that he's in he's in the water
and he comes out of the water he reaches
up he says hey Julien bring the boat
over yeah it's a shock so hey there's
like it but and then he goes back down
no I mean there's a shock in the water
near I'm probably a reef shark and um
he's got his spear and he just like just
get closer but I'm still fishing like
that's that's the life so he just wants
to be able to get out of [ __ ] go
sideways yeah yeah I'm assuming but I'm
like scared would you think that it
would be safer to be in the water or on
top of the water if there was a shark
look if you had goggles you could see
the [ __ ] wouldn't you want to be
in the water rather than on top and not
knowing where he's coming from I would
think so I would think so but then you
like not only is it 360 but it's like
universal the view is universal right
right but if you're on top of the water
and you can see at least is like you got
your back to the wall and you can't come
from the top that's true so that's true
but I don't know but I'm at the same
time you
the water with an animal who's who
that's his natural habitat like you
can't you can't even turn around nearly
as fast as he can he can probably swim
around you and come up from the back
before you could even turn around yeah
probably yeah
they swim pretty [ __ ] fast yeah
they're like ninjas in the water they
just clean the cleanup crew just like
that tiger I am so i girlfriend I were
there and I was on feeding the Turtles
right so I try to grab a turtle and
literally the turtle is this big it's no
bigger than this and I'm about to pick
it up I'm trying to pick it up being
like explain to people oh I'm sorry yeah
I'm probably like 16 inches Leo trashcan
lid no bigger than a trashcan lid and I
am trying to pick it up and this before
I can get it out of the water
those big fins arms that they have he
just he pulls me down into the water
like this this little thing he probably
weighs 40 50 pounds right and it's just
so powerful in the water like if I would
have hang on to that turtle I would be
moving faster than I would move with
fins on whoa like how is that part and
I'm like I don't want to talk about my
weight but I'm a lot bigger than that
I'm not fight weighted you're eating
well um you look good man don't worry
about it do you think you're gonna move
to Bahamas you think he'd live there
someday um I like ultimately I'm
definitely gonna live back there you
know my lifetime you know I am I mean if
I want to I want to die there whoa I
know I mean I don't necessarily want to
die anytime soon
but when you do you want to live the end
of your life there a relaxed life I on
life
[Applause]